quick thinking between employees led to
a heroic child rescue right here on
these stairs a man grabbed a
ten-year-old boy out of the water luring
him under the pretense of being the
mother's fiance but two employees at
coeur d'alene paracel didn't think it
was right
around eight in the evening surveillance
video shows a man approaching the coeur
d'alene paracel booth with a child
immediately the kid went around me
and kind of hid behind me
and stated
i don't know that man and he's not my
dad police say the man insisted he was
the boy's father but paracel owner jamin
rodriguez said something was wrong after
moving the child out of the way and
questioning the man he told rodriguez he
would quote get the boy's mom rodriguez
discreetly called the police but kept
moving so
then he started heading back down the
dock and i'm like i'm like riley you
stay with the kid find his mom i'm gonna
go follow this guy because we can't let
him go if we let him go he could be gone
forever rodriguez has kids of his own
and felt the danger of the child who was
now hiding behind him he followed the
man for 15 minutes around the lake
updating dispatch on his every step much
to the man's dismay he's like stop
following me
leave and go back to your booth and i
was like no
he's just like a main actor in like a
horror movie like that kind of creepy
oddness meanwhile his employee stayed
with a child and went to find his actual
mom he goes she's right there can we run
and so we both started to run to her he
was crying super sad the boy's mother
says everything feels surreal but she's
so grateful for the help of the men the
most important thing to take from this
story is people are just more aware of
the fact that
that this stuff could happen in our
little town of coeur d'alene
when police arrived the suspect john
marshall randolph was booked into the
kootenai county jail for one count of
child enticement
randolph has already been bonded out but
the boy's mother and the employees say
they are moving further in the legal
process so that this suspect stays off
the streets and away from children
rodriguez adds that if you have a gut
feeling you might want to trust it
because you could potentially save
someone's life in coeur d'alene morgan
trow krem 2 news
shout out to the employees who did the
quick thinking and handled it including
following the guy and getting the police
to actually arrest him so they wouldn't
be able to get away um so i think it's
always commendable i think when people
do good and shout out to the two three
people the employees who help this young
individual what are your thoughts um
yeah that's a mess it's out there it's
out there don't stop saying that you
really think it's gonna it's gonna
happen to other people not you with
surveillance you have a false sense of
security
because you're around your house because
you're in your own town because you're
close to home you're not safe i don't
want to be sounding too alarming and
[ __ ] like that but yeah it's it's it's
crazy out there there's a lot of crazies
out there and the more and more we go
the more and more there are some uh
mental health issues are not dealt with
and uh
so that means a lot of them people out
there walking around
walking around and about and they can
handle they can do whatever the hell
they want to do so you have to be extra
vigilant you think this is particularly
mental health or do you think this is
more like a child predator
what's the difference
well mental health issues doesn't
necessarily overlap or doesn't have to
that i think there's a correlation with
mental health and being a chopper
predator there is there is a correlation
there is some issue some trauma that
happened that's been that's been noted
and seen there is a trauma whenever you
have a child predator or molester
is a correlation with trauma that
happened hence mental issues
what's this correlation with trauma
there's a there's a trauma of the past
that makes that
um
there's um whenever you have a child
molester or someone that is in that like
a predator whatever that there is a
correlation with
a
uh so
go ahead
so you have to be careful right so
actually yeah i do have to be careful go
ahead
okay this is getting into the weeds of
stuff and honestly
this is a whole discussion that i think
is
i don't even like having because people
are so reactionary when it comes to
stuff like this you're right it's just
like you can't say anything without
people what the [ __ ] do you know like
okay but if you guys want to be informed
the vast majority of people who end up
getting involved or middle kids whatever
are people within a family or people who
are close relation to the children
abductions taking random kids out like
that's that's that's the rarity
vast majority of incidents where people
get touched or whatever
or from people that know them parents
uncles caretakers that's how it happens
90 per night like mass majority okay so
people you need to be worried about
technically speaking are the people who
are taking care of your kids not randoms
okay
that's that's fact number one well
there's a lot of things like that but
i'm not just talking about people that
deal with kids there's a lot of things
that can happen to you kids just okay
the reason i'm saying that like that is
because not too recent well actually
yeah very recently
in montreal there was a guy that
assaulted a 10 year old girl for no
reason and i'm talking about
beating the kid
unprovoked that's mental issues so
there's a lot of things that can happen
to your kids
you have a sense of security because
you're close to home uh it's only uh one
mile away it's only 800 because you're
close to home you think nothing can
happen but
yeah it's as a parent i think it's very
like
it's a it's it's rough because you don't
want to like
you want to be a
in france we call that like the
translation of french is uh a helicopter
parent someone that's always roaming
around okay
you don't necessarily want to be doing
that but
you got to protect your kids from the
things that are i'm not alive bro
as kids we were wild
i mean i remember staying out past 10
p.m outside the park
walking home by myself
i'll be going up to the grocery store
i'd be going up to get fast food on my
own biking anywhere i wanted to go as
kids we did whatever we wanted whenever
we wanted past 10 at what age
oh i'm talking about young young
like 12 and below
12 and below we was wildin
yay
yeah yeah you would see the sun setting
and you'd still be out and you'd be like
all right sun's going down it's time for
me to start making my way home but if
you think about it vast majority of that
[ __ ] was unsupervised was it not for you
mm-hmm not past ten because you was a
whole savage
but
when you were in the neighborhood
yeah i've seen some hoods around my way
that it was that was that was that was a
thing yeah
yeah that's why dave chappelle's joke
about the baby on the corner selling
crap
even though that's not real did you you
did remember
on the street
yeah
that was common
so
khq spoke with someone who was close
with john marshall randolph the person
who was caught and uh you know arrested
by cops
the man who was accused of luring a 10
year old to come with him tuesday on
lake coal that in
the person who knows him says he's very
dangerous
this person who asks us to conceal her
ideally has known randolph for years she
told us over the years randolph has
threatened her her family and said she
feels unsafe around them he's a ticking
time bomb and you don't know when he's
going to relapse
she said mental she said randos mental
state has been deteriorating
but when he takes his medication he's
able to hold it together
when he's on his medication he's still
a little off but he's able to function
but when he's off his medication he
escalates stuff and thinks people are
after him court documents filed in 2020
show randolph had a concussion in late
february of 2018 and that's when cl
those close to him saw a change in
behavior documents said that he started
to believe he was a soldier of god
when the pandemic began documents said
that really affected his
mental illness he thought that april 5th
was going to be the end of the times
that the world was coming to an end
whoa this is crazy she says that she
asked police to visit their home to
check on john after receiving a series
of disturbing texts they said they found
him with a gas mask on and his gun in
his lap i felt like if i was there he
would have locked
up he would have locked me up like a
hostage situation where he thought it
was dangerous out in the world
huh so this takes a different turn so
now
i mean listen it's no safer for the
child but it's what you said
it's what you said i see it in the
streets
even before the pandemic
working outside being a bouncer you just
in the street you see it and just like
every year every year you see more and
more of them yeah faces i don't
recognize faces that disappear faces
that don't make it yeah i talk to these
people too i talk to homeless
[ __ ] too
you tell me who they lost
have an interest conversation with them
yeah you take some and you leave some
but
it's not good
and not taken care of
whenever there's a city that said that
they have a problem like montreal where
we at right now they say that they have
a homeless people problem
the problem is not that they are there
and they want to get rid of them
the problem is that they're there
and their solution is just to get rhythm
up
get rid of them every time we have the
club hee here which is the formula one
whatever the hope the police they take
them in
so that the tourists don't see them yeah
they hide the issues they are the
problems
it's like when you when you invite all
your family members over and you tell
your sibling to go in the room and lock
them yay
except no you put them in the room and
you lock the door then you soundproof
the [ __ ] and be like
put a little towel in the bottom yeah
but at that but as a thing that that's
the thing so there's more and more of
that and people because they're not
necessarily inherently bad people but
because mentality is deteriorating and i
got people in the health system and in
the mental health system it's not good
lesson has resources here's the thing i
want to raise this to also the audience
we have this perception that was more
dangerous to us because the fact that we
were out all the time these kids are
accessible to everybody because online
social media so even though they don't
leave the house uh
the outside still comes to them yeah so
i wonder which one's more dangerous
you think so yeah really
you have to go outside
we were all outside
period but now you have the outside you
were at least when you were going inside
you were going inside and i was that
okay now you outside
and the outside of outside can still
reach you meaning outside of your
country outside of your city i can still
reach you with your phone and stuff like
that plus the outside that's just outed
at it outside i don't really make sense
but you understand what i'm saying
there's a lot of parameters so yes i
believe that today yeah i said power
meters again okay two days more today's
worse because there's more there's more
of that i already know the audience is
going to agree with you okay because
everybody has a recency bias you know
what recency bias okay it's like when we
say oh this person is the greatest of
all time this is the greatest athlete of
all time this is the greatest player of
all time it's because it's the most
recent memory of what grace means that
we always do that okay so there's a
certain but if you agree you agree maybe
there's no reason so i'm not gonna you
had you had you had but you had to bike
at 10 and be a kid
but here's my that was broad daylight
here's my thing go go ahead here's where
it gets spicy okay
it is much more difficult today
to get away with any crime than it was
way back then
we grew up in the [ __ ] wild wild west
where crimes were happening all the time
and it never even came to the police
because they never end up finding out
well then when will you have
the crime the fact that you get away
with it doesn't absolve the fact that
you it when you get caught by the
footage crime
it already happened we're not talking
about him getting caught or not we're
talking about you okay get hurt
being dangerous right so even yes it's
easier to get caught right now than it
was back then
it would happen more today than back
then because it's easier to reach yeah
[ __ ] are gonna get caught
[ __ ] gonna get caught the ones
that we know of right now no not my
brother's gonna get caught up right now
period it's harder to get away with a
lot of questions yeah i know but the
crime is done
i get you that the crime is done but as
a result
if i'm pretty sure this has been true
over the last a lot but if i looked at
the statistics of crime they're all
weighed down compared to when we were
growing up and before us i wouldn't know
if you're telling me that because you
have the facts well i mean be it violent
crime being a whole bunch of other stuff
sun arrives right now huh it is on the
rise right on the rise right now with
the pandemic that's literally been the
last two years before that it wasn't the
case obviously with the global pandemic
everything kind of shifted after that
but before that everybody was inside and
there's more crime that's crazy
well not necessarily because crime is
more so linked to poverty and
opportunity obviously with inflation
being higher homelessness rising sure
everything becoming more expensive
literally tracks
with poverty
and
those things track and so my question is
people talk about like oh things felt
things were safer back when i was
growing up i'm like were they safer or
did they just feel safer and because you
didn't have access to information you
weren't aware of the fact that crime was
happening everywhere in smaller
communities or other communities you
just weren't being fed that if that
right so me i i question this perception
that things are more dangerous now than
they were before so you think it was
safer and safer now
what are we comparing give me years
whenever the [ __ ] you were 12.
i was like what 2001 too
yeah i'd say we say for now i feel safer
today than i did with them yeah
i feel way safer today than i did back
then
yep okay what about you i don't even
know
hobby breath not as you say remember you
remember you going out at that time and
[ __ ] getting stabbed and beaten out
and stomped out these [ __ ]
don't do that [ __ ] they do that in broad
daylight now what you mean if we talk
about this city what do you mean i can
only compare about this city okay
[ __ ] were shooting when i was
going out
just in the clubs right in the clubs
they doing that in broad daylight here
now can i ask you isn't this a recent
development of the last two years
absolutely okay so let's take just
before the pandemics i feel like the
pandemic is a big event that kind of
changed the world yeah okay so we're
gonna we're gonna take that aside yeah
if we take that aside yes you would
agree yeah okay i'm not okay i'm not
crazy when i was thinking about the time
period i'm like bro
you're crazy but not for that reason
i appreciate that
i am a little cuckoo yeah you're crazy
not because of that but but yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
so uh second part of this story i know
we went on a little tangent and then
we'll have that
we'll have that conversation on the
theater's channel let's let's have that
conversation we're gonna talk about
crime scenes yeah yeah if you guys want
we got a podcast channel you can check
out apple vs vs preach so go check that
out on youtube you get full length
podcast episodes there for you to check